Hello 大家好，这里是山河作用。我是Sofi，我是SanSan。
今天我们邀请大家和我们一起上一堂地理课。
这一期的想法其实就是因为我和Sofi出去徒步的时候，经常会遇到一些无法解释的问题。
比如说这个山为什么这么坚，这个山为什么是有一个横切面，然后它的石头为什么是一层一层的。
冰塔林它为什么形成？
如果冰川都化了，上海还在不在？
就是很多这种地质地貌方面的问题，然后我们没有办法解决。
我们就想，哎呀，要如果有一个地质学家跟着一块徒步就好了。
所以呢，我们就邀请了一个地理老师，他是真的是地理老师，然后当时他还是一个做地理科普的一个博主。
然后来跟我们聊一聊，就户外人比较感兴趣的一些地理知识。
虽然我们之前准备了一份采访提纲，但是中间很多问题都是我们临时插进来的。
有一些是我们日常徒步的时候几暂的一些跟地理相关的问题，正好我们都一股脑泡给张老师了。
对，可能有一些在大家听起来会比较白痴，有一些问题呢，可能就会特别入门。
我觉得就是大家就当着跟着我们一起来学习吧。
对，是的，如果你也有一些你徒步中遇到的跟地理相关的还没有被解答的问题，你也可以留在留言区。
没错，我们可以再问一位张老师。
反正今天我们就是两个虚心的学生来补补课。
那欢迎大家一起来跟我们听课了。
哈喽张老师，先跟我们的听友简单介绍一下你自己吧。
各位小伙伴大家好，我叫张老师，然后是一名高中地理教师，也是一名热爱徒步的地理科普博主。
我的小红书和等于的名字叫做地理的地理，主要是科普一些生活中常见的地理现象，也顺在纪论我的一些徒步的经历，欢迎大家来关注。
我其实就是在小红书上刷到张老师的。
对，然后我是看到散散推送给我的分享，然后他说，哎，你看一下这个很有意思。
今天我们三个人，一个是地理老师，一个是曾经的地理科代表。
不好意思，他有缘分。
在地理老师面前怎么能提这个，趋趋不值一提。
还有一个就是地理学渣，说实话，我初中的时候地理经常不及格。
没事，初中地理不重要。
今天我们就好好来上这一节课。
喜欢上徒步以后才发现，在户外的时候，地理的知识还是非常有用的，现在才开始恶步。
其实之前我和三三在徒步的时候就曾经就闲了嘛，什么样子的徒步搭子是最完美的。
肯定是要有一位职务学家能介绍我们看到的沿路的这些花花草草。
然后还有一位是地理学家，地质学家，就是能帮我们介绍经过的地形啊，地貌呀。
所以我们特别有幸能邀请张老师来跟我们上一堂地理课。
谢谢，谢谢。我也非常有幸能够和你们一起交流。
那你作为地理老师，你也是一个户外爱好者吗？
那你去了户外是不是就像开了天眼了？
就是别人看到的都是风景，但你看到的都是几亿年的地质运动，会这样吗？
确实看到的风景会比一般的可能要更加丰富一些。
比如说我看到一个山，我会知道这个山应该是怎么来的，然后未来它会怎么演变。
所以这些就是一个第一反应，或者是下一式的反应。
当你来到户外的时候，你看到这些你首先会去思考它的一些和地理啊，地质相关的一些信息是吗？
是的，是的，而且感觉作为一名地理老师根本就没有假期。
因为一旦看到好的风景就要把它收集起来，作为自己的商货素材是想给学生听。
所以别人去户外是放松，你去户外是备课？
对，所以我们地理老师放假出去玩没有任何一点那种不上班的负责感，就觉得自己都是在上班，都是在丰富自己的教学素材。
那非常名正言顺了。
是的，是的。
如果作为地理老师肯定您的专业之前在大学里也是学的地质地理相关的吧？
实际上我本科学的不是地理，本科学的是经济，然后后面我考研考了地理专业，因为我自己高中以前就对地理特别感兴趣。
哦，所以你当时考研的时候就是因为对地理感兴趣选择了这个对吧？
是的，是的。
因为之前高中田资源的时候很不幸没有被这个专业给录到。
那学地理专业的话是不是有很多这种野外的实践呀？
确实是有挺多的。
像我们学院里面的话，每年都会有老师会带你出去外面去研学，去什么新疆这些，去看一些那种风景，同时也去解读背后的一些奥秘。
当然那些是大学教授的解读就比我们高中的老师会更加的深入很多了。
那如果学地理的话，再往深入的研究，它会再分不同的门类吗？
其实地理学它的构成非常的复杂，就感觉其实什么都叫地理。
比如说有地球物理学，城市地理学，什么政治地理学，就任何学科它都能和地理成上关系。
是的，是的。
我自己在写提纲的时候我才发现怎么地理真的什么东西都能包含进去。
那你说气候气象可能也算，地质地贸也算，然后植贝啊什么这些东西，其实可能都跟地理还是沾点边的。
是的，是的。
其实所有这个地球表面的，其实都可以给它归为地理。
只要跟空间分布扯上的关系都可以叫地理学，如果它没有谈空间，
如果只是某个具体的科学原理的话，那就可能更像其他学科本身的东西。
我现在都不知道高中地理到底学啥呀？
高中地理就是啥都学，然后啥都不经。
大概呢，您现在教的那个学生教到哪一课了？
我们现在已经上到区域发展那一个部分了。
什么?
就我们是这个布局区域发展，就是我们高一上期学的是自然地理学，
就什么气象啊，然后地质那些，就跟徒步很相关的。
然后高一下学期学的就是人文地理学，比如说城市化呀，然后产业这些。
然后我们高二这个时候就开始融合我们高一学过的基础知识，
再放到一些区域里面去理解。
比如说我们就举个例子，比如说北京，我们去研究它这个地方的区域发展。
我们就会用到前面学过的自然和人文地理的知识。
这就是我们大概的一个架构，然后到后期就主要是复习这些部分了。
哎呀，已经开始听不懂了。
那回到就是您作为一个地理老师，然后同时也是一个地理博主。
您大概会有用什么样子的频率去来到户外。
就是你是带着一个什么样子的心情，或者是前提去看这些风景了呢？
其实我这儿八经的接触这种徒步是去年，
因为去年我暑假第一次去西藏旅游的时候，
然后我们我首先用自己所学的知识，然后找了一个非常冷门的景点。
然后我女朋友去了之后发现了景点，特别的惊艳。
哦，是哪儿啊？
西藏博密一个地方叫白埔龙沟。
哦，知道。
然后当时我们那个地方是需要徒步几个小时才能到的吗？
然后当时我们去的时候还有几个其他游客，
然后我们就发现我们自己比别人走得快，
然后就觉得我们是不是有徒步的钱呢？
然后我们就去开发徒步这个东西，
然后结果从去年暑假到现在基本上每一次这种小商家，
我们都会去徒步。
但是平时因为像我们这边特别的卷，
我们这边高中很卷，
我们这边连周末都没有，
所以其实去户外的时间也不是很多。
对，科教尔是高中老师的忙碌程度。
所以我平时的话就是主要才是周边的一些，
因为像我们这边属于四川盆地的边缘嘛，
所以我们周边也有一些种比较小的景点，
也能够满足对户外的一些好奇心。
但是我真正向往的是那些雪山和冰川。
那其实在四川的话，
已经算是一个离户外非常近的一个有独特优势的地方。
是的。
那你有自己特别偏爱的想看的地形或者地貌吗？
我比较偏爱的是冰川。
我去的每一个那种徒步的地点都是有冰川的，
而且我特别想离冰川更近一点，
所以一般的那种景区已经不能满足我的这种需求了。
那目前在中国冰川比较多的，
是不是就只有西藏？
西藏川西还有云南，
就是这一片高海巴地区都有，
然后新疆也有。
就是为什么作为第一老师来说冰川这么特别呢？
首先我从高中到大学都在学习冰川，
而且从站在专业角度上来说，
当你看到冰川的时候就意味着沿途，
你会看到很多其他丰富的风景。
它是一种代表，
比如说我徒步如果说能够走到冰川的话，
那就意味着我能看到森林，
还有草原，还有荒漠等一系列比较复杂的东西。
这是一方面。
另外就是冰川它确实是一个非常非常特殊的一种自然景观。
因为平时我们生活中的地貌都是什么水，都是什么风，
但冰川它是一种非常暴力的塑造地貌的方式，
所以我就对冰川特别的着迷吧。
你说的冰川是一个特别暴力的吗？
对，它是种塑造地貌的一种非常暴力的方式。
你可以展开讲一讲吗，
为什么它是特别暴力的？
比如说我们跑去一些低海巴地区看到的一些山，
它的外形都是比较圆润的，
因为这些地貌大部分都是后期被水给塑造的嘛，
水是比较温柔的方式。
而冰川塑造地貌它就是一个固体，
一块巨大的冰它在山上形成之后，
在往山下滑的过程中就把沿线的一些岩石给它破坏。
所以我们看到一些高海巴地区的山，
它就特别的风力，
因为它其实就是冰川这样直接摩擦出来的。
那冰川形成的必要条件是什么呢？
比如说它要在一定的海拔之上，
然后我在想，冰川是水形成的吗？
还是雪形成的呢？
并不是所有的高海巴的山都有冰川，对吗？
其实冰川就需要一个条件，就是要够冷，冷就可以了。
然后在我们地图上来说的话，
高海巴地区和高维都地区都有冰川，
比如说像加拿大还有北极南极有很多冰川，
然后在我国的话，主要就是一些海拔，
基本上在四千米以上的地区才有冰川。
那有些地方感觉没冰川，
主要是因为，
第一个可能是它海拔不够高，
第二个是因为冰川它其实是有一些鸡血，
不断的累积这样压出来的，
它不是水直接结冰形成的，
然后这些鸡血压实的这个地貌环境的话，
一般都是在山谷里面。
我记得我和Sophie，
我们之前去加拿大徒步的时候，
走过一个冰川，
然后当时我们那个巷岛，
就随手捡了一块冰起来，
就说这块冰可能就已经是两百多年前的，
雨水或者是雪，
然后景城的了，
就是冰川这个东西它形成，
是需要很长一段时间对吗？
是的，是的，
就是你可以想象一下，
它就是每年冬天的时候下雪，
这个雪一点点的堆起来之后，
下面就压实了变成的冰，
所以你如果有机会去西藏。
或穿一些冰川的话，
你可以看到那个冰川就像一些岩石一样，
它是一层一层的，
它就代表了不同年代这样不断的堆起来，
这样有过程。
因为我记得我去冰岛的时候，
会有一个项目是坐船到那个冰湖，
去看它浮在上面大大小小的那个冰川，
因为它最深处是有一个冰川的冰川壁，
然后它是很大一片，
然后不断的会有小型的冰川，
从上面剥裸，
然后那些浮在湖面上的小型的，
可以说浮冰吧，
能看到就像年轮一样，
就是一层一层的，
然后可能有一层会有点杂质，
或者灰尘，
然后上岛就说，
那层就说明在那一年发生了火山喷发。
对，因为冰岛它是一个火山喷出来的岛嘛。
所以根据那个冰里面可能存在的杂质，
或者是昆虫什么的，
是不是就可以判断这个冰到底是哪一年的？
是的,
像我们国家每年都会去南极北极科考，
他们就采用一个方式叫做砖，
在冰里面砖出一个这种冰体出来，
检测里面的成分，
就可以判断这个地方曾经的一些气候演变。
说到这里，
我想到就是有一些那种科普，
或者科幻的文学文艺作品，
它的一个前提的设置就是，
从什么万一年的冰川里面，
释放出某种病毒。
是的，是的，
确实还是有一定的科学道理在里面的。
那我那个加拿大的冰川，
当时我捡了一块还舔了吗？
挺长了一下时间的味道。
那现在国内有能走上去的冰川吗？
国内只有野生的冰川可以走上去，
景区的一般的不能走上去了。
是出于保护的目的对吗？
还有安全考虑？
主要是安全，
因为像我国的冰川，
基本都是那种叫做海洋性冰川，
就是这个冰川它的发育速度特别快，
它的移动速度特别快，
所以它的表层会有很多碎石，
如果你靠近那个冰川的话，
就可能被碎石给砸到，
所以我们国家的冰川一般是很难接近的，
除非你去徒步去一些比较野生的地方。
对，刚才你说这个，
我国的冰川大部分是海洋性冰川，
我记得当时我们去西藏那边取灯泥马，
然后它有一个冰川吗？
当时说它那个冰川特别特别，
因为它的形成的原因，
还是因为一些其他的原因？
取的泥马冰川的话，
它属于大陆性冰川。
对对对，我好像印象中是有这个。
对，它这个划分主要是看这个冰川，
它的水分的来源，
因为取的泥马，
它的位置比较内陆，
所以海洋的水溪不容易到，
因此它的水溪主要来自于大陆里面，
所以它的那个颜色，
还有它的形状，
就和川系的冰川会有很大的区别。
当然这个冰川听说好像疯了，
对，所以我很想去这里看，
但是没机会，
以后估计也没机会了。
嗯,
但是其实我们也没有办法接近它，
只是远远的看一下，
也不知道为什么要。
走到它脚下。
我在网上见过一些博主，
他是靠近那个冰川的，
就在以前。
哦，我知道了，
其实我们去的那个，
好像不是真正的取灯泥马冰川，
是叫什么铜壶，
还是什么来着？
真正取的泥马，
应该是五八冰川。
对对对，
五八冰川，
那个我们其实不是五八冰川，
就是它隔壁。
对,
所以其实颜色也会不一样。
是,
像取的泥马，
这种大陆冰川，
因为它的水气来源比较少嘛，
所以空气中的粉尘也会很少，
所以它就看起来很干净，
而像川系的冰川，
就看起来有点灰灰的，
有点脏脏的。
那其实我还有一个问题，
是关于冰川的，
就是因为，
就是现在我们看到，
很多很多关于这个，
气候啊，
地质的一些，
比如说科普，
或者是，
就是号召大家，
一定要保护环境，
什么温室效应之类的，
然后就说，
这冰川都是在退化，
然后,
而且退化的速度，
是非常非常快的，
那所以说，
所有的冰川，
都是一个在，
消亡的状态嘛，
还是说，
就像你刚才之前说的，
它每年的下雪，
会逐渐的累积，
形成新的冰川，
那现在，
会有新的冰川在形成吗？
整体来说，
都是在消亡的，
只是说它的季节，
有点区别，
比如说，
穿西的冰川，
它可能就是在冬天的时候，
鸡血再补充它，
然后在夏天的时候，
它在消亡，
那么总的来看，
目前来说，
就是消亡的速度，
是快于它，
鸡血再补充的速度的，
因为毕竟气候在变软嘛，
就是下的雪，
没有原来多了，
主要是融化的快，
其实下雪的量，
那个倒影响不大，
之前我们去西藏的时候，
我们就看到一个，
很大的一个，
冰川草谷，
当时那个巷岛就说，
这个草谷，
在它们小的时候，
那里其实被冰川盖住了，
但现在冰川完全化了之后，
就变成一个，
很荒凉的一个干谷去了，
那假如真的有一天，
世界上的冰川都，
全部都化了，
它对人类生活有什么影响吗，
对我们？
首先最大的影响，
应该是，
会导致海平面上升，
特别是南极和北极的那些冰川，
它其实储存了很多的水在里面，
如果它们全部融化的话，
估计像什么上海中城市，
都会被完全的烟冒掉，
然后像内路的一些冰川的话，
可能影响小一点，
但是可能会影响当地的一些，
比如说用水的问题，
像川西西藏很多地方，
它们喝的水，
其实主要就来自于冰川融水，
如果这个冰川一下子融化没了的话，
那后续的水质原因，
其实也是不够的，
当然还有很多，
其他的影响什么，
生物多样性这些，
但是世界上的，
地球上的水不是横钉的吗，
就是它化了，
它可能就在河里，
我不知道，我瞎说的，
但是它不会回到内路，
内路必须那么干旱的地方了呀，
总量它是不变的，
但是我们现在大部分的淡水，
都是储存在冰里面，
比如说南极和北极的冰，
它们都是累计在海平片以上的位置，
那么如果它们都化了的话，
就全部融到海里面去了，
变成显水了，
海水我们是不能直接喝的，
我们只能喝淡水，
冰川真的是一个珍贵的东西，
是的，是的，
所以我一看到什么冰川，
我就想着赶紧去看，
我就怕以后看不了了，
那你有什么，
比如说新院清单，
一定要去看的这个冰川的列表吗？
国内的话，
可能比较想看的就是，
西藏的，
就像你们刚说的，
徐德妮玛冰川，
还有新疆的那个，
牧社塔格的冰川，
啊,
国外的话，
像我之前见过加拿大有一个，
不是加拿大，
好像是阿拉斯加吧，
有一个世界最大的冰川，
张熊名字我忘了，
我也想去看一下，
但是现在应该没什么机会，
像冰塔林什么的，
跟冰川，
冰塔林是长在冰川上的东西，
对吗?
其实冰塔林，
它就是冰川的一种形态，
啊,
因为冰川，
它这个固体嘛，
它在往山下，
滑的时候，
因为它前后的速度可能会不一样，
比如说前面的坡都斗一点，
那前面滑得快一点，
后面就滑得慢一点，
那这个时候，
这个固体，
它就会裂开，
裂出很多缝隙，
然后再融化，
就形成了那种冰塔林的样子，
啊,
就滑得慢的变成了冰塔林了，
嗯,
它先裂开，
裂出了很多个缝，
然后这个缝，
它的顶部，
滑得快一些，
所以顶部就会变尖，
所以冰川，
它其实可以拆分的理解，
第一个是冰，
第二个就是川，
川就是在流动的意思，
我们看到的冰川，
都是在流动的，
只是速度比较慢而已，
为什么冰川融化都是，
我感觉它都是从底下开始滑的，
有很多原因，
第一个是从我们人的视觉来看，
上面融化了水，
也会流到下面去，
上面看得明显一些，
这第一个，
第二个就是，
冰川在移动的时候，
它的底部会跟那个，
地面发生摩擦，
这个摩擦就会，
加速它底部的融化，
嗯,
哇,
真的地主老师，
真的所有的问题都能接住啊，
哈哈哈，
其实,
大部分的地主老师，
是不在这东西的，
主要是因为我特别喜欢冰川，
所以说我看了很多，
跟冰川有关的，
书籍，言论文这些，
之前我也是不懂的，
说到颜色这个的话，
我其实一直就很好奇，
比如说我们去，
西藏也好，
或者去川西也好，
或者去国外的一些地方，
比如说像加拿大班夫那边，
它都有很多高原湖泊嘛，
但是它那些湖的颜色，
有的是带一点绿的那种蓝，
有的是那种保实一样的蓝，
有的是牛奶色，
对，有的是那种牛奶蓝，
就是什么决定了，
这些湖的颜色，
差别这么大呢，
那是矿物质吧，
这个就比较复杂了，
有些是因为矿物质，
比如说那个冰川的，
冰川的粉末，
它就是比较偏蓝色的，
然后在一些那种咖啡的地貌区，
因为里面有碳山盖嘛，
那么碳山盖它就，
更加看起来像蓝绿色，
比如说像九寨沟那种地方，
然后还有一些其他的泥沙成绩物，
它的颜色也会不一样，
如果是低海拔的湖泊的话，
那可能就是里面那些藻类，
生物本身的颜色，
你想大一点，
这个其实是非常非常庞大的一个，
学科了可以说是，
所以其实比如说像九寨沟的湖，
它看起来湖水特别清澈，
它几乎就直接能看到底了，
你感觉它就是透明的，
但是同时它又有一颜色，
它其实就是，
因为里面还有很多的碳山盖，
它可以反射一些蓝绿光，
所以看起来就很鲜艳，
原来如此，
很多户外的高手啊，
他们其实都不是看轨迹的，
他们可能会看，
地图和等高线啊，
什么这种，
它看等高线，
它其实就知道哪儿是悬崖，
哪儿是比较斗的坡，
您作为地理老师的话，
能不能用简单的方法，
给大家解释一下，
怎么能看懂等高线啊？
其实判断等高线，
是我们高中，
乃至初中，
地理的一个重点，
就我们为了让雪层掌握这东西，
总结了很多口诀，
比如说最简单的，
判断坡都是看等高线的，
疏密程度，
就如果一个地方等高线，
很密集的话，
那它的坡就会很斗，
然后如果判断斗崖，
就更简单了，
因为斗崖，
其实就是在一个地方里面，
它的高度变化很大嘛，
那在等高线图里面，
它就是看出来，
是几个等高线，
重合在一起的，
那么它就是一个斗崖，
然后另外，
比较重要的就是，
判断一些地贸，
比如说判断山谷和山脊，
那么,
在一个弯曲的等高线里面，
如果这个等高线，
它是突向高处的，
那么这个地方，
它就是一个山谷，
如果突向低处，
那就是一个山脊，
酸酸的CPU在燃烧，
这个可能语音不好形容，
这个如果，
拿一个图出来，
对,对,
现在需要做一道题，
到时候，
我们把这个图放在烧肉子里，
但是,
但是我其实还是觉得，
因为如果看等高线来判断的话，
你毕竟大脑要处理一遍，
可能有时候在户外，
没那么直观，
所以我平时，
一般还是喜欢用，
一些比较立体的图，
比如说二维地图，
来看一些，
地体的那个，
会更加直观一些，
那像你平常去户外的话，
你会,
就是自己去通过，
地图，地质图，
就是叫什么图，
地形图，
对，地形图，
会通过地形图，
和比如说像，
卫星地图，
类似去，
自己,
设计你的户外路线吗？
看什么地方嘛，
如果是去一些，
比较危险的地方，
我可能还是会去，
参考一些，
成熟的线路，
那么如果是，
像去我们，
这周边这些，
我比较熟悉的区域，
那我就会在地图上，
去,
自己设计一个路线，
像我们学校的，
这个地理，
地理组，
我们几个老师，
有时候去外面，
考察的时候，
打开一个，
卫星图，
看它的等高线，
然后在，
那个软件上，
画一个线出来，
然后我们研制的线，
去，进行一些考察，
如果是去一些，
陌生的，
那种高海拔地区，
我还是不太敢，
自己去，
设计的，
因为里面的，
电速太大了，
比如说我的目标，
就是远处的那个，
牙口,
那些探线的人，
他们怎么知道，
我怎么能走到那个，
牙口,
我怎么能，
设计这条线路，
走到牙口，
我觉得这个，
感觉很难，
是,
最近原则，
还是说，
最一走的原则呢？
我觉得，
一走,
应该是更重要的，
很多地方，
比如说，
在爬山的时候，
如果说，
在设计条，
从山脚，
往山林爬的路线，
那就尽可能走，
简单的路线，
所以,
探线一般，
怎么探的呢，
就是沿着，
山谷里面探，
因为山谷，
它的坡度往往，
是比较缓的，
然后,
什么水源，
也比较充足一些，
所以,
它的要素是什么？
我觉得，
首先,
第一个就是要安全吧，
我觉得要远离一些，
那种落石，
比如说，
如果你的上方，
有一个很陡的陡遥的话，
就要离它远一点，
特别是，
在高海拔地区，
白天可能没什么问题，
但是,
晚上的时候，
落石会增多，
因为晚上，
那些石缝里面的水会结冰，
然后,
把石头给这样直接撑开，
就很危险，
哦,
是因为这个，
我还以为，
是由小动物，
出来活动呢？
可能也有，
但是,
因为你白天，
根本就没感觉，
白天感觉好像，
那石头好像不会动，
但晚上的时候，
会掉下来，
然后还有就是，
可能要尽可能，
远离一些那种，
河谷的底部，
有可能会有洪水，
是吗?
非常对，
就是河谷，
它的汇水条件很好嘛，
然后还有一个，
可能大家比较容易忽视的，
就是一些木道，
就是那些牛羊，
会经常走的，
这样一个路，
像之前，
我有一个朋友，
他就是去录影的时候，
把帐篷扎在那木道上，
然后晚上的时候，
被一些牛给，
就我觉得，
安全是第一的，
这个可能是，
扎到了牛的十字路口上，
对,对,
就是你如果，
看到那个地上，
有一大块那种，
草被踩突了的话，
这种地方，
一般的不是人踩的嘛，
那肯定是牛羊踩的，
就要离它远一点，
原来如此，
对，当你满足安全之后，
你再去追求一些，
舒适度，
比如说地形平坦，
然后视野开货这些，
如果在山脊线上，
扎营呢，
其实有一个风险，
就是山脊线，
它的风会特别大，
因为它两边，
没有什么遮挡嘛，
然后像一些特殊的位置，
比如说横火那个什么，
熬太线，
它就在一个山脊线上，
它是一个横灌东西的，
一个山脊，
然后南北两边的，
冷空气，
在这地方交会，
就导致你天气的，
变化可能会特别的大，
所以山脊线，
一般不是一个，
理想的扎营的场所，
当然还是要看，
距离的情况而定，
所以其实是半山腰，
然后被风的一个，
平坦一点的地方，
是比较好的，
对,对,
还是要靠近河谷吧，
但是就不要离谷地太近，
因为这种地方，
可能它就会取水啊，
安全性跟方面，
会稍微的好一点。
刚才你提到那个熬太线，
那你能不能从，
第一老师的角度，
给我们，
就是再，
解释一下，
为什么熬太线，
如此危险呢？
其实我看了这么多，
那种视频，
熬太线发现出事的原因，
从人为原因，
角度上来说，
多半都是因为，
装备不齐全，
然后从自然原因，
角度上来说，
天气变化太大了，
像高中的学生，
都应该知道，
就是熬太线，
它是我国的，
南北方分界线，
它是好几个分界线，
什么零度等纹线，
还有,
八百毫米等疆水量线，
这个分界线，
就意味着什么呢？
比如说，
冷空气的分界线，
北边是，
冷空气占据主导优势，
而南边是，
暖空气占据主导优势，
然后你刚好站在，
中间这个位置的，
山际线上，
所以如果你今天，
上山的时候，
你可能觉得，
穿个短袖都OK，
但如果明天，
突然间，
冷空气变强了，
那这个迅速的降温，
就会引发一些危险，
所以这个地方，
危险性，
就是跟它的一个，
特殊的位置，
还有它的一个，
走向有关。
所以就是，
冷暖空气交界的地方，
它势必就会容易，
降雨对吗？
强对流？
嗯,
不是降雨，
你可以举个例子，
比如说，
像你们北方，
冬天都会，
开暖气了对吧？
在北方的时候，
冬天你，
如果完全在室外，
你会觉得，
没什么问题，
因为你习惯了，
对不对？
然后你如果，
完全在室内，
你也觉得没问题，
但如果让你站在门口，
一会儿冷，
一会儿暖，
你就会出问题，
那么,
熬天就像在门口一样，
这种,
就是,
冷暖空气交汇，
它会导致什么样的，
天气问题呢？
比如说，
它会容易起雾吗？
或者是，
对，很容易起雾，
因为,
雾其实就是，
水气凝结嘛，
然后暖空气，
它提供了很多水气，
然后冷空气，
就是夏天，
特别热的时候，
还有冷空气，
下来吗？
夏天,
可能会，
少很多吧，
少很多，
但是毕竟那个地方，
它是一个，
交接待附近，
所以,
还是会有，
两股力量抗衡的时候，
只是说，
夏天可能暖空气，
整体要强一些，
冬天就反过来，
那像中国的，
各种山脉，
是不是只有秦岭，
是这种，
情况比较特殊的呀？
秦岭,
应该是最典型的，
因为它刚好是，
东西走向的嘛，
然后,
我国的暖空气，
往北推进，
然后冷空气又反过来，
就理论上来说，
任何一个，
这种海拔，
3000米上的山脉，
都会存在这种情况，
是,
因为我记得，
好像,
就是,
离北京比较近的，
那就是五台山嘛，
很多人，
会去那边土布啊，
或者越野跑，
就经常，
在夏季举办的那些，
越野跑比赛，
会说,
那个,
遇到了暴雪，
降雪,
还有冰雹，
对,
冰雹就是，
典型的那种，
强对的天气，
比如说，
因为那个地形的原因，
吹到天上去，
然后就马上的凝结，
产生很多的，
降雪，或者是冰雹，
所以张老师，
你能根据，
刮风的特点，
你能判断，
它接下来，
会是什么样的天气吗？
比如说，
它就是起雾，
或者它未来，
会有冰雹这种，
这个不太好，
不太好说，
因为天气，
它变化是非常多变的，
只是说，
有些现象，
可能会比较反常识，
比如说冰雹，
大家可能觉得，
冬天会比较多，
其实不是因为，
这个天冷形成的，
它是因为天太热，
导致这个气流，
迅速的上升，
就会凝结产生冰雹，
感觉气象，
又是一个，
特别复杂，
和大的门类了有，
对，气象，
气象非常的复杂，
气象学，
研究了这么多年了，
我们依然无法，
准确地预判，
一个地方的天气，
会怎么样，
特别是在高海吧，
地区一海，
是，那些山里的小气候，
对,
小气候非常多变的，
其实对于，
人来说的话，
就是有很多山，
以及包括，
他们的气候特色，
都是大家，
比较喜欢讨论的话题，
那其中一个就是，
这个横断山脉，
然后,
也就是，
张老师你，
所在的，
四川地区，
他,
离得比较近的，
一个非常有名的山脉，
那对于这个，
横断山脉的话，
它有什么样子的，
地质,
或者是气象特色呢？
横断山脉，
它其实就是，
四川盆地，
和青藏高原的，
一个分界线，
然后山脉，
它是好几条山脉，
这样,
南北走向这样过去的，
那么从四川盆地，
往青藏高原走的话，
我们就会，
穿过多条横断山脉，
然后逐渐的爬升，
所以,
这个山脉对于我们这边，
最大的印象就是，
第一个，
它反映了我们这地方的，
地质非常的活跃，
比如说，
为什么成都，
还有什么汶川，
有这么多的地震，
其实就是因为，
横断山脉的脚下，
它就是，
板块的交接处的附近，
它地质非常的活跃，
所以这边，
地震很多，
然后滑坡那些，
都很多，
是从地质方面来看，
然后另外，
从气象来看的话，
横断山脉最大的作用，
它就是能够阻挡，
来自东边的暖湿气流，
如果有去自家过，
穿藏线的朋友的话，
应该会经过一个隧道，
叫做二郎山隧道，
这个隧道就是从，
四川的亚安天泉线，
连接干自独立线的一个隧道，
这个隧道，
刚好穿过了横断山脉，
游东往西走的第一条山脉，
所以说，
四川盆地那种，
非常糟糕的阴雨天气，
但你一旦穿过这隧道之后，
你就会进入一个大晴天，
马上从四川盆地一下子，
进入青岛高原，
所以它能够阻挡很多的水气，
导致两边的气候，
出现非常大的差别，
那它两边的植被，
应该差别很大吧？
对，非常大，
像四川盆地这边的话，
植被就比较的丰富嘛，
有很多的那种扩叶树这些，
但你如果穿过隧道之后，
到那边，
就基本上，
树就很少了，
就是一些，
一些草啊，
一些那种比较干旱的，
甚至还有仙人掌。
还有仙人掌？
所以仙人掌也是中国的，
原生植物吗？
对，仙人掌，
它不仅在沙漠有，
它在川西其实也有，
因为川西，
恒旦山脉的每一个河的边上，
都会有仙人掌，
这种东西叫做干热河谷，
就你们以后有机会，
可以去一个地方，
叫卢定县，
就飞朵卢定桥那个卢定县，
那个地方就是个
典型的干热河谷，
然后它的公路边上有很多的。
野生的仙人掌，
非常的神奇。
感觉真的中国是，
地大雾泊，
就是所有的这些，
地形地貌的，
有特点的，
都能找到对应的地方。
我现在的感觉就是，
大量的知识，
涌入我的大脑。
是的，所以，
所以真的我觉得，
其实中国的这种，
徒步资源，
还有旅游资源，
已经非常丰富了。
我觉得，
如果能够在有生之年，
能够把它探索的，
差不多都已经很满足了。
那我想到有一个，
就是说他们都说，
中国没有的一种地貌，
就是峡湾这个地貌。
对，峡湾是中国没有的。
那我去三峡的时候，
我觉得是三峡，
就是峡湾。
其实峡湾，
它是一种冰川地貌。
峡湾那个湾，
它其实就是冰川，
在滑动的时候，
压出的一个槽，
然后这个后面，
因为气候变短，
海平面升高之后，
海水把那个槽给填进去了，
这个叫峡湾，
所以峡湾一般，
只会出现在一些
高维度地区，
因为你看像中国的冰川，
都是在高海宝地区嘛，
这个地方不可能被海水淹到的，
所以中国就没有峡湾。
但是三峡是淡水，
所以三峡不算。
三峡那个地方，
它其实是，
长江直接在那个石灰岩里面，
直接切出来的，
是流水切出来的。
所以它是先有水，
然后峡湾是先有湾，
然后才有水。
对,
峡湾是冰川切出来，
然后再水填进去，
然后三峡那个，
它就是水直接切出来的。
原来如此，
学习了好多。
我觉得真的，
张老师，
就是我们这次，
其实借着这次，
聊天的机会，
然后去解答了我们，
那个过去积累的，
很多的疑问。
知识盲去。
对，知识盲去。
我觉得弟弟的灵魂是实践，
就是,
现在我看到很多的，
包括我的同行，
他们掌握了非常丰富的。
弟弟知识，
但是他们都没有去，
真正的去实践过，
我觉得还是有点可惜的。
我反而特别羡慕，
你们有很多的，
这种实践的机会和经历。
我如果念书的时候，
有一个这样的弟弟老师，
我觉得我弟弟，
应该不至于不及格。
那其实回到刚才，
就是关于中国的这几个山脉的话，
我还有一个想要请教的，
就是关于这个高丽贡山，
像我们之前去，
到腾虫那边土布马，
然后也在高丽贡山的，
算是边缘，
近距离的接触过，
然后当时是，
我们看到的信息是说，
高丽贡山，
它是一个，
植物的保库，
因为它有非常非常丰富的，
这个植被啊，屋种啊，
所以从地理的角度，
您怎么去看这座山呀？
其实高丽贡山，
它也属于很难山脉的一个，
蓝端的一个山脉，
然后它，
植物保库，
我们可以这么去理解，
就是,
不同的植物，
它需要不同的环境，
那植物保库，
就意味着，
这地方的环境非常的多，
那环境多靠什么来实现呢？
第一个，
就是它的伪度比较低，
所以它的热量比较充足，
所以一些比较热带的植物，
可以在那里生长，
然后,
又因为它的海拔比较高，
所以从高丽贡山的山脚，
到山林走的过程中，
它的气候会逐渐的开始变冷，
降水逐渐开始变少，
所以就能够满足其它的一些，
这种植物的生长，
所以高丽贡山，
它就是我们的一个保库，
然后整个云南，
它也是我们的一个植物的保库，
这个它的伪度和地形有很大的关系，
像我们徒步的时候，
其实随着海拔上升，
它植被也是在不断变化的吗？
是的,
比如说你到了多少千米以上，
那种高大的植物，
比如说冷山，
什么山数就开始没有了，
然后再往上的话，
可能就只有一些低矮的罐木，
什么之类的，
是的，是的，
那有没有一些简单的方法，
看植物就能判断，
我们大概在什么样的海拔呢？
因为植物的分布，
它不仅受气温的影响，
然后也受降水的影响，
然后海拔升高的话，
最大的影响是气温，
降水不一定是海拔越高，
一定越少，
所以大概来看的话，
如果你看到一些那种。
不会落叶子的那种扩叶数，
就基本上是海拔，
可能一两千米那种地方，
如果你看到那种真叶数，
那种叶子比较尖的，
然后看起来很硬的那种叶子，
那基本就是海拔，
三千多米的位置，
那么在四千多米以上的地方，
就基本上只能看到一些高山杜卷，
然后四千五以上的位置，
可能就是一些草殿，
草原,
然后再往上走，
到四千九左右，
可能就草都没有了，
全是那种石墨，
那种乱石堆，
石墨,
哪个墨？
荒墨了墨，
因为石头很多，
就像沙墨一样，
就叫石墨，
但是其实云南和四川，
可能还有一些植物，
细微的差别，
可能还是会有一些不同的，
或者是在这个山的象洋坡，
和被阴坡，
它其实也会有不同的差别，
这样我想起来了，
其实我去新疆徒步的时候，
其实一直觉得，
应该是仰面数更多，
但是结果我发现，
其实是在
阴面,
阴面数更多，
对,
为什么呢，
树不都是喜欢光和作用，
它需要阳光吗？
我们可以这么对比，
就一个地方，
如果不长树，
它又长草，
然后树它不是更喜欢什么，
而是树它比草的生长，
要求更加的苛刻一些，
就如果是在一个缺光照的地方，
那树可能就分布在象洋的位置，
但新疆不缺光照，
光照反而是一个负面的东西，
因为它缺水，
所以光照太强的话，
阳波反而会，
真发太强而缺水，
所以树就会长在阴波，
这个样子？
是的，是的，
你的观察也是非常的细致了，
对，光照非常的细致，
而且像有些地方，
你可以看到新疆那边，
它的树长在山上，
不长在山脚下，
那这种就是因为，
可能是因为山脚下，
它的这个水，
地面的积水太多了，
然后树长不了，
就只能长一些那种，
比较耐潮的，
这样一些草，
所以这个是一个，
非常庞大的一个现象，
每个地方的原因，
可能会不一样，
太有趣了，
就是如果大家出去土步的时候，
多观察的话，
会发现很多很多，
这种有趣的地方，
是的，是的，
那我之前听说过，
说大家如果不知道方向的话，
可以通过青苔来指示方向，
比如说北半球的话，
觉得青苔只长在，
比如说石头的北边，
这个在户外实践中，
这招真的靠谱吗？
这个理论上靠谱，
就是我只考虑光照的情况下，
确实靠谱，
因为像北半球，
因为太阳主要在南边照过来嘛，
所以南边，
它的这个蒸发强一些，
水分少一些，
而青苔，
它是一种更加，
洗湿的这样一种植物嘛，
但是一旦考虑了，
其他因素之后，
这个东西就变得，
没有任何的意义了，
比如说很多的山，
它的南坡，
它既是阳坡，
也是阴风坡，
那阴风坡，
它的降水就有很多，
而且往往很多时候，
阴风坡的影响，
会盖过阳坡的影响，
比如说还有个例子，
就是喜马拉雅山，
南坡是阳坡嘛，
我们都知道阳坡，
它的太阳浮射墙，
那应该，
鸡血会更少一些，
但是,
喜马拉雅山，
南坡的鸡血反而更多，
就是因为，
它是一个阴风坡，
它的降水很多，
来自印度洋的暖湿气流，
是的,
看来,
高中地理学的不错嘛，
果然是地理科代表的，
是的,
第一,
又重新回到脑子了，
那这样南坡，
是不是更难爬呀，
南坡是在尼波尔那边，
对吧,
理论上来说，
会更难爬一些，
因为它的气候更复杂嘛，
但是它的坡度，
应该是更缓，
但是南坡，
刚刚我们讲到的，
就是南坡，
它光照充足，
然后降水也充足，
然后落差也比北坡更大，
所以它的景观，
可能会比北坡，
更好一些，
哇,
太复杂了，
地理真是博大精神，
是的,
地理设计面太广了，
所以我每天都在
不停地学习，
那像在徒步的时候，
我们在树林里，
如果想要找水远的话，
什么方法可以判断呢？
我觉得找水最好的方法，
就是看地形，
像水它一般都会往地处走嘛，
所以说我们在找水远的时候，
尽可能的往一些山谷里面找，
这才是一个，
我觉得比较，
成功率比较高的方法，
如果说是，
通过直背来判断，
可能就是要去一些那种，
比较干旱的地区，
比如说你去新疆，
旁边都是草，
这个地方长的树，
那可能这个地方的水源，
可能会相对充足一些，
那我们再聊聊气象吧，
看云之天气，
在北京，
有一些人会去预报，
今天晚上的晚霞指数，
或者明天的朝霞指数，
这个预报它，
评判的一些决定的条件，
大概有哪些？
这个我没有详细去研究过，
但是,
这种朝霞晚霞的话，
其实大概就是，
根据第二天的云量来判断，
首先第一个，
如果完全没有云龙的话，
那是没有的，
那如果云太多，
把那个光完全挡住了，
可能也没有，
所以云量在一个，
比较适中的时段，
那大概的一回出现，
那云海呢，
就像我们徒步的时候，
如果能，
就是看到云海，
会是一件，
觉得非常幸运的事，
那如果，
我们想去看云海的话，
您推荐是在，
一个什么样子的，
气象条件下，
去看,
也不太好说吧，
因为,
其实云海它就是，
因为水气在某个高度，
出现了集中的凝结，
然后,
如果要看季节的话，
像夏天，
云海的高度，
可能叫更高一些，
因为夏天气温更高一些，
所以说，
它凝结的话，
那水气要再跑高一点嘛，
然后冬天的时候，
可能高度就要低一些，
可以这么去看，
就有一个，
我觉得比较简单的方法，
就是你看一个地方的，
天气预报，
比如说，
之前我去四川康定徒步的时候，
因为康定市区，
它是在一个海报，
比较低的位置，
然后我要去它旁边的一座海拔，
四千多米的山上去徒步，
然后我就看，
康定它是阴天，
那就意味着，
康定它是被云给盖住的，
那这个时候，
我跑得再高一点，
我爬了四千多米的位置，
我就可以看到那个云海了，
然后当时我去验证一下，
发现还是，
基本上可以这么做的，
等于你爬到了云层之上，
是的，是的，
其实想看云海，
其实很简单，
就是你爬得够高，
然后当天，
山上的天气又没那么好，
那就是云海，
因为如果是万里无云的那种大蓝天，
就怎么着都不可能看到了，
对，对，对，
那还有一个，
我觉得户外徒步的时候，
尤其是夏天，
大家比较关心的一个问题，
就是夏天容易下暴雨，
容易打雷嘛，
有那种雷电天气，
那如果我们在户外，
刚好遇到雷电的话，
怎么躲避，
或者是在什么位置，
会比较安全吗？
雷电的话，
我觉得，
其实我们，
应该都有些基本的常识吧，
究竟可能避开一些，
那种突出来的物体，
比如说一些大树，
一些那种比较尖的，
突起来的石头这些，
然后尽可能的去一些山腰，
这种位置会好一些，
所以其实，
如果是在山里的话，
又遇到了打雷的话，
最好是在，
很多很多树的，
树林里，对吗？
对对对，
就是你不要去，
去一个明显，
更高的那个树的下面，
因为它，
它的引力作用会很强的，
嗯，如果是一个很空曠的草殿，
然后我站在那儿，
我是最高的，
那我就很危险了，
对对对，
如果是，
比如是山脊上，
只有一棵树，
那我站在树底下，
也很危险，
是的是的，
不要做最高的那个，
对，其实你看，
我们建筑上面，
毕雷针，
它就是做最高那个嘛，
哦，那我躺一下，管用吗？
但是你毕竟靠在那个树的旁边，
所以它把雷引过来的，
然后,
你也就跟着遭了，
如果我在树底下，
但是穿着，
橡胶雨靴，
管用吗？
你非常多假事，
在,
你可以这么想象一下，
就是雷，
它可以穿过空气，
披上地面，
你就意味着，
哪怕没有什么理想的导体，
它其实也会披到你身上来的，
哦,
好的,
还是安全低，
对对,
遇到下雨天，
我还是及时下车吧，
对对对，
下车是最好的选择，
呃,
那,
我们想聊聊，
你的手机里，
会不会有什么使用的，
跟户外图部，
或者自然相关的，
APP呀，推荐的，
我手机里就大概，
三个APP吧，
第一个就是，
两部路，
这个大家应该都有，
呃,
可能我跟别人去面，
在于别人是，
直接用两部路来导航，
而我是会把，
两部路的轨迹，
传到,
澳为地图里面去导航，
那你用澳为地图是，
什么呢？
因为澳为地图，
它是可以看等高线，
可以看3D的，
这种立体的地形，
所以它会比，
两部路更直观一些，
那个澳为地图的，
软件叫什么呢，
有推荐吗？
它名字就叫，
澳为地图，
这个APP名字就叫，
澳，澳妙的澳，
澳为地图，
哦,
对对对，
好,OK,
天心呢，
我就用那个Windy，
这坏人，
对对,
这就比较常用的，
而且就是我会用，
澳为地图来打，
而不是用，
直接用两部路，
所以就是你会在，
澳为地图上，
就是把，
两部路上的轨迹，
输进去，
然后同时看一下，
它的地形和地貌，
对,
因为它的那个轨迹，
可以直接，
叠加到那个，
立体的地图上，
因为它，
澳为地图上，
咱们中国的，
每一个地方，
都闪掉进去了，
都是立体的，
所以它就会非常的直观，
前面的坡有多陡，
我一眼就看出来，
我不用去，
汪老师，
你的Windy,。
有充汇员吗？
没,
舍不得充，
我觉得基本的够了。
用Windy,
看那个天气的时候，
是有什么绝窍吗？
其实Windy,。
它是一个很复杂的东西，
我现在也没有，
去充分的开发它，
其实我的用法，
可能跟大家也差不多，
就是我定一个位置，
来看它，
未来的天气变化，
然后其实我也发现，
Windy,
它在,
穿西种地方的话，
它的准确率，
其实也不高，
就是选择出去土步的时候，
还是要看，
这个季节的一个特征吧，
比如说穿西，
它的雨季，
可能就是在，
4月份到，
7、8月份这段时间，
这段时间，
你,
哪怕你看到Windy，
是晴天，
你过去，
很有可能也是雨天，
所以我觉得，
判断红干的气候，
可能比，
看未来的天气，
会更加的，
靠谱一些。
那比如说，
有一些热爱户外的朋友呢，
想了解一些户外的，
地理知识，
你有推荐的，
书籍,
或者是纪录片吗？
怎么说呢，
因为,
然后这些现象，
都是一些比较特殊的现象，
书籍和一些那种，
纪录片，
都是比较偏大众的，
所以说，
我目前还没有找到一个，
比较适合大家看的东西，
我就以我的经验为例，
我出去，
如果看到一些，
不懂的东西，
或者我想，
深入了解一个地区的话，
我推荐一个网站，
中国之网，
看论文。
哦,
如此学术，
对,
因为,
因为其实很多地方，
都已经被那些学者，
研究的很清楚了，
而且,
不要害怕，
因为,
真的很容易看懂。
真的吗？
真的,
我们,
我们不用看，
不用看他的那些，
什么复杂的，
研究方法和，
那些什么公式啊，
数学那些东西，
我们只看，
他的结论就可以了，
像我去川西，
我去的每一个地方，
我都是，
提前下这个地方，
论文来看，
然后,
我就大概知道，
我去的地方，
有什么东西，
然后需要注意什么呢，
因为,
地理的东西，
我觉得门槛真的很低，
它跟其他的学科不一样，
我记得之前，
什么冰气壶啊，
什么冰斗啊，
然后我专门，
去查这些东西，
到底是什么，
还先学习了一下，
才能看得懂那本书，
那我再推荐一本书吧，
大学的一本教材，
叫地貌学原理，
里面没有任何的，
数学公式，
全是大家都能看懂的，
包括像冰川，
它会有非常详细的图解，
哪个地方叫冰气壶，
哪个地方叫冰石壶，
哪个地方叫什么什么，
冰蛇这些，
它很清楚，
我觉得，
喜欢坏人的朋友，
应该去买一本来看一下，
第一个它很简单，
第二个你看了之后，
真的会感觉，
就有一种，
学的这是有用的感觉，
特别是当你走过这些地方的时候，
你再去对照，
再看回去的话，
可能就是印象就更深刻了，
对，就是我每次出去，
我就觉得，
哇，这个是我以前学过的，
然后这个我还，
这个我还不懂，
然后我还要回去再学一下，
我第一次出去徒步的时候，
我就啥也没去，
准备就出去了，
然后就感觉很多东西不懂，
然后回来我就，
开始去恶捕我之前，
见过的一些不懂的现象，
然后下次我在出去的时候，
我就发现，
看到了，
然后这个是我刚刚看过了，
就很有那种，
很有掌控感嘛，
就感觉，
就感觉这一切都不会，
让我感到陌生，
不会让我感到害怕，
那张老师，
当你去户外的时候，
你的包里会有，
就是像我们常规的户外用品，
之外的一些神器的东西吗？
显微镜，
这倒没有，
显微镜那个太，
太专业了，
其实我也不是很专业，
我其实，
跟别人没有太大的区别，
但是我觉得，
我有个还有就是，
我特别爱记录吧，
然后我出去徒步的时候，
我都是，
左手拿个Pocket3，
然后,
右手,
主了登山帐，
然后脖子上还挂了个，
几英镇的相机，
然后,
每次都很累，
但是每次回来之后，
去反复的看这照片，
就觉得，
很有收获，
我之前，
见到过很多出去徒步的朋友，
他们都是，
走到终点之后，
然后,
手机拍一张照，
然后就走了，
就是我觉得大家如果，
出去,
还是尽可能多去记录一下，
多拍一下，
当时你会觉得很累，
很麻烦，
但是回来之后，
会很有收获，
比如说，
像我徒步的时候，
有时候，
看到一些山，
它的那个岩石，
是一片一片的，
就感觉你手都能，
给它剥下来的，
那样的石头，
当时就会觉得，
这个还挺神奇的，
这怎么会这样呢，
但是可能，
当时也就拍个照片，
然后回来就忘了，
可能也不会，
进一步的去搜索，
就是说，
哎，为什么这个地方的，
地质地贸，
会是这个样子的，
因为现在AI，
也很发达了嘛，
一天回来，
如果实在找不到答案的话，
没准问问AI，
也可能会有答案，
是的，是的，
就当你能看懂风景的时候，
而不是单纯的，
欣赏风景的时候，
你会对这个徒步，
会有更深的认识，
你会更喜欢这个事情，
对，是的，
就像有时候去，
有一些的山，
可能它是，
原来是海底，
挤压,
然后那个叫什么，
浮上来，
哎，不对，挤上来的，
挤压之后，
龙起台身，
对对对，
你看这些专业店的，
我都不会说，
然后呢，
它那些石头里头，
有时候会有一些
贝壳的画石嘛，
对对,
如果你了解这些的话，
那你可以稍微多留个心眼，
没准你能剪到一块，
带贝壳的画石，
放在家里，
我觉得也挺有纪念意义的，
对，就刚刚你说那种，
一层一层的岩石，
你们可能就会发现画石，
去北京周边这样的岩石，
还挺多的，
对对,
我们还去过一个
特别有特色的那个地貌，
就是那种，
六边性的玄物岩，
你说柱状结礼吗？
对,
哇好专业啊，
对，玄物岩柱状结礼，
是,
因为我们去内蒙那边，
然后它那边不是有火山嘛，
对,
然后它就会有一些地貌，
它是能看得非常清晰的。
那种柱状结礼，
然后能在那种
大大小小的六边形的石块上走，
那个就是火山的岩浆，
从里面慢慢流出来之后，
它冷却收缩形成的结礼，
就跟风潮一样，
因为风潮它其实就是，
一种比较理想的结构嘛，
那那个岩浆，
涌出来的时候，
它冷却也是个理想的结构，
刚好是六边形，
对，那说到这些
特别的地形地貌，
就是,
张老师你有没有走过哪条线路，
会觉得这个，
地貌特别丰富，
然后你特别推荐的吗？
其实我走的线路都主要集中在。
川西和西藏这边，
因为,
因为我去过这些地方之后，
我就感觉，
那些更加低的那些山脉。
就没有太大兴趣了，
然后这些地方的话，
我推荐两个吧，
就如果你是一个新手，
就是那种普通的游客，
那种,
稍微爱好户外的朋友的话，
我推荐去，
就是我刚刚说的那个白铺龙钩，
在西藏临织的波密线，
这个地方，
它就有非常丰富的，
古代兵船和现代兵船的地貌，
而且它的强度不大，
就是我当天就可以徒步往返，
风景非常的好，
我觉得，
然后如果你是一个。
比较专业的户外爱好者的话，
我推荐去的是，
中山风冰塔林，
也是我去过最略的一个地方，
那个地方需要徒步3天的时间，
然后爬山要超过3000米，
但是那个地方，
有一个好的地方，
就是它的景观特别的丰富，
因为你是直接从海拔。
2000多米的地方，
爬到海拔5000多米的位置，
然后那个地方，
刚好又是在
横断山脉的最高峰，
就是共瓦山的东坡这边，
所以它的植被啊，
还有各方面的景观，
非常非常丰富，
但这个地方非常危险，
我之前去的时候，
我们那个营地就有一个人，
高反然后叫救援下山了，
所以我觉得，
就根据自己的情况量力而行吧，
我得出的一个结论就是，
越危险的地方往往风景越好，
所以量力而行，
张老师，
你刚才说的那个冰塔林，
它叫什么名字，
能在水？
中山风，
你们听说过海螺钩吗？
听说过，
海螺钩旁边，
就在海螺钩旁边，
这个冰川其实比海螺钩还漂亮，
但是因为它没有开发，
所以只能徒步去，
但是风景非常美，
非常美，
而且你可以走进那个冰川，
直接摸那个冰川，
因为我们俩其实还挺重草，
去看冰塔林的，
因为之前去到那个西夏邦马，
对,
但那个海拔有点太高了，
那个海拔太高了，
对,
没有这个勇气尝试，
但是在那个山脚下的话，
就是当时搜了一下冰塔林的照片，
然后就觉得非常动心，
冰塔林的话，
我觉得比较好接近的就是，
刚刚你们说的那个巨灯泥马，
还有西藏的牧社塔这种，
川西的冰塔林，
基本上都是要爬很高的路，
冰塔林是不是其实很高啊？
怎么说呢，
就大概两层楼左右那么高吧，
两层层那么高，
其实我们看那种广角的拍的远，
远的照片，
倒是不觉得好像它那么高，
其实它可能你走到身边的时候，
发现它是一个巨大的冰塔林，
对，是很巨大的，
哎呀,
挺像网的，
但是不知道自己体能，
能不能走得到呀，
很略,
我就是我第一次去那个西藏那个地方，
根本就不交徒步，
它就是一个游客多走一会路，
然后我就觉得，
我们就觉得我们应该OK去徒步可以，
然后结果我们直接，
第一次徒步就去了这个冰塔林，
然后当时就被略惨了，
当时去了之后我们才知道，
我们才知道原来这个路线，
是给那种老驴去的，
我们两个新手就跑去了，
回来以后有没有想要好好锻炼，
然后下次再挑战，
对回来我就包了健身房，
因为去了哪里之后才知道这里，
究竟有多菜，
但是我觉得，
我们居然成功的坚持的下来，
我觉得说明我们还是有那么一点点天赋的，
已经很厉害了，
对,
但是我们，
我们以后再也不去这种地方了，
太危险了，
真的很危险，很吓人，
但是你不是很喜欢冰川吗，
如果想要看冰川的话，
我觉得好像所有的线路，
基本上都不会太容易，
有很多容易的，
比如说，
也是在那个地方旁边，
有个地方叫乐多曼音，
是,
那个就很容易，
那个我之前，
之前我自己去了一趟，
然后我还跑到冰川上面去，
摸了一下那个冰川，
那个近两年很火的一条线，
就是新疆那个南天山北线，
好像也有冰川，
对,
但那个有点危险，
因为那个是冰川上面走，
对，是的，
所以那个必须得找，
熟悉的向导才行，
对,
那个最好要结伴而行吧，
我觉得未来我们去徒步的时候，
可能还会有各种各样的，
跟地理相关的问题，
所以大家可以关注一下，
张老师的小红书号，
我就看你小红书，
分享那个什么突暗，
凹暗啊，
然后那个，
比如说突暗会水流缓一点，
它会浅一点，
凹暗就是水流，
会急一点，
深一点，
这种,
然后我就觉得推有趣，
因为,
每个人会从这个里头，
得到不同的知识，
比如说有的人喜欢去游泳的人，
他就会知道，
那我要离那个凹暗远一点，
因为那个水流会比较急，
对,
然后呢，
我就看评论里有钓鱼的人说，
哎,
凹暗水流急，
所以那儿鱼多，
我要去那儿钓鱼，
是的，是的，
我就觉得地理真是好有意思，
就是你不同的人，
能从中得到不同的，
不同的用处吧，
对,
我对地理的看法就是，
他可能对，
可能你大学学地理专业，
对你找工作，
可能没什么帮助，
但他对你的生活，
会有很多的帮助，
那我们也特别羡慕，
张老师的学生，
能有一位，
这么有趣，
然后懂得分享的老师，
我也还在努力的学习中，
那我们谢谢张老师，
今天来跟我们聊天，
好的,
谢谢,
那今天先这样了，
拜拜,
想要加入我们的，
听有群的朋友，
可以微信搜索，
上合作用的全拼，
加小助手，
他会把你拉进群里，
大家也可以在小红书上搜索，
上合作用，
关注我们的小红书账号，
我们会在上面分享一些，
播客以外的花絮，
多少的泪泪始终爱我杀，
刻意再问几着信，